In 98 days,
European elections will be held and as of 1.
times all young people can vote from 16
I have 2 news one good one bad and the one for it with solution 1tens
the voter turnout is relatively low
actually not so good news
but means
that the influence we young people can have on the election results.
is significantly higher than usual
and this is important
because we young people we vote majority progressive
we have shown this for example at nembundestagswahlundzwanzig 21
so means
when we young people all go to the european elections now
then we can have 1 progressive European Parliament
That we need for important packages of legislation for more climate justice
social justice and more humanity in the external borders
the problem
voter turnout is quite low,
especially among young people
because many do not know
that the election will take place or,
in the case of first-time voters,
that they may go and vote.
the solution is actually obvious we have to burn it
so share this video
talk about it with your friends at school in uni
and let's do it